Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to "Bad Dream: Coma".
Now we're going to the old house which I'm assuming-
Oh.
It's in the forest.
Ohh...Good...My goo pursuits are still here, but I-
It has something to do with this kid..
"GO AWAY"? No! No no no no. I'm gonna correct that one, you don't tell me how to do that.
I am the master.
Oh my God...
That's why everything is torn.
Oh! A-and things just got flipped!!
What the hell?
Wow.
I mean, I guess my pen ran out of ink so I can't do that anymore, but that's why everything is like drawn!
And that's why nothing makes sense.
Oh, it's a trading card. Ah, it's that guy! Look how- look how good he looks. You want sausage?
Oh. Alright then.
But that's starting to make sense... Now I get it. So there's more to this than you'd think there would be because -
It's all drawn. It's all the imagination of this kid. It's all part of a bigger world...
It's all part of the world that doesn't.. necessarily mix...
The fuck...
Aaaa....ahaha....
AH!
I got scrissors!
I don't know - hoooow...
Oh.. my God. That's why everything's taped up! All the inner machinations of it.
Oh, the screen settings!
Oh...That's why everything's a scribble...
Oh!
Can I cut something out of this? Ookay. I cut THAT out. It's the rest of the gun!
It's a picture of this!! "I'm warning You..." Oh, you ain't warning me enough! Blaaap.
Ohmygo-
OOOOOoooooo-
-ooh shit.
Hi... You guarding the house, you creepy bastard?
God..
Don't stare at me.
This looks familiar- What is that?
Treasure map...top secret...map...Key
The frick
*gasp*
That's so weird
Because this is from the original games
Like this this here this house. I remember this it was all piecemeal, but I remember it
Oh my God, I knew this was gonna have a payoff I knew that it would.
There's some secret here to be found. There's something more to be explored who wants this goddamn sausage
Why do I have this goddamn sauces, but there's something more here? There's a lot more here
And it's all has to be ok I get it I get it you don't want me to go inside
I get it. I get it. I did ok but
According to the map the Key is in
Maybe its not
Maybe it's not I got the key anyway. Oh
shit, dude
Dude, uh oh my God that's so cool. So I get the key. Oh, it doesn't go to that
But that was smart of me
You know I?
Should make it look smart because of them, whatever ok so there's got to be something else for this key to go to right
What would this be go to? Huh?
obviously not those
Why is it marmol happy why is everything dying?
Like if it's all a drawing does it all need to be drawn every there every once and while in maintain obviously he's erasing something
Like I'm part of this drawing and it's all getting out of hand
Here today more obvious that that guy's head off
ah
Keep it back, huh pass
Okay, I got a pass
I'm eligible to be here. Oh, I regret going in here immediately I
Don't like that whispery. I death
Hello, okay. I didn't like that
Should I go back and get the fishing pool? I'll take that. Thank you. Oh
Somebody's I broke pass happy day. Oh poochie. Oh, that's so happy. I think
You want a sausage moon took you out of there or a crowbar you I don't know
oh
Wait the sun. That's it. I gotta cut out the sun it, but that's your eyes. It's bright, baby
It's bright baby crowbar on that cut it out. Oh, I love the way that all that I
Can oh no spike oh?
No
It looked creepy at first, but now I guess it's okay. Oh
It's creepy again. It's immediately creepy. Hello. I would do would you like a sausage can I offer you a Kielbasa
Well kill bye
Creepy oh, bye spike. Oh my God read your spike and death oh
I'm sorry, oh
I don't know what's going on there, but alright
Ok this is the room of yeah, this is the room of all
Remember it don't forget it. Yeah. Oh, they're the same now oh
Ok can't go in there yet apparently oh
Hi, ok whoa? Oh, why did I get a dirty rag out of the out house that's
disgusting
Would I do that, I think you did self
All right, well anyway. I just pick up everything I find so
dirty Rag it is I
Hi death, hows it going? How are you?
Get out of here
Ok well apparently I'm not dead the door closed on me
Didn't kill me
Death sure is merciful these days
Alrighty then alright, okay, well
Duly noted I guess. I'll just be on my way then oh
Okay, I didn't know I could break in there well
I broke in with the crowbar okay, and I and I go then sorry death. I'm now officially a criminal
I'm breaking and entering oh box
Fucking you kidding me. Why'd you do that? We don't remember that you want a sausage?
Hey, okay, sausage. God, and I didn't want to do that ow
Owie
I remember that in the original game he had fingers cut off though so cool. Anyway. I got scissors. Though. They bloody didn't mean to
Anyway, I got him
Okay, well I got scissors again. Wait. Did it oh it took my scissors, but now I got them back, okay?
But what can I do with Bloody scissors?
They're gonna ruin it. I wasn't ruined my game. Yeah, so I'm assuming that everything is well and did
Oh, I washed the rag. Oh it's clean now
That's nice
That's real nice. What am I gonna? Shed? I returned the rag
Who want the rag? What's a nice clean Rag? Oh?
Oh you want to oh, oh?
That's the one that was screaming. Oh, I got a broom. Oh, there's that car that crashed earlier
Anyway, nice. I got I got a broom - stay with me dad. I love you so much
Is that deer death please don't take my parents you can have all my toys. I'll clean my room every day
I promise I know sometimes, I'm rude and impolite, but I'll change I'll do anything just don't take my parents
I beg you I'm sorry. I have to don't try to stop me D.
Well then
Okay, oh that looks like a lot of tax
Sweep sweep sweep lambos you want sausage all right anyway with that all right crowbar no
Mrs., cool
Who's down there happy mother's day? I love you very much
Because old families died so he's not a kid anymore
Which is something that I was actually?
suspecting like he's just a kid here because like he's trapped in this weird world that he's
Created or something like you know what I mean
Like there's something more to it
Weird I'm still bloodied up believe it or not
But I am just don't know why I got these schizos though nick couple one of their heads. Oh
So he got married and had his own kid
So here oh
I get it. I get it I get it is there anything that that one's preventing me from seeing?
something
here
Sausage no blob. No there's something there though. There's a drawer that hasn't been open yet. Maybe I'll be able to open soon
Hey, how's it going? Now? You still here yep? Hell, that's me. I'm going down these
Nuts
Get out I don't wanna you took my stuff
oh
Screw you no, I don't think so blue fusion. Hey back to normal oh
Kindly look no
I'm warning you yeah
You really scary dude hmm. I'm so worried. I'm
so
Scared right, but there's got to be more stuff here
That's all the sam. I'm just checking to make sure nothing's changed. There is something there, but I'm completely out of all my stuff
Okay, so where did all my stuff go do I have any of my stuff left was there a reason for me to have those?
Scissors, and I've already wasted that reasoning. That's entirely boy
Give give give give yes worms magnifying wait there was something in that inventory list that it didn't say blue scissors
Give me all of those things. I want all of them
But I think it's these are the early drafts for the first game
Kid didn't want to make games. Oh
Hello, Teddy, boy. Army to stop death
Don't like that. I didn't see that before I
Don't know how you stopped death. Maybe you could your death last warning no
Oh, oh, I need to be warned like 10 jillion times
You can't warn me enough
Right, but I can't go here anymore
It's got to be something else, right?
It's gotta be something else. Oh
Okay, oh, I got a handle maybe I can use the handle on the thing
Oh, I did it. Okay parents from basement ok I need to take this take this give me that whoa never mind
I'll just go there directly then anybody want a sausage down here your rooster. You want a sausage you cac
Alright fine, then I'm fed up. I've asked I've warned is it so hard to understand that I want to be alone
I don't want to make people sad anymore
People are scared of me and delay meeting me as long as possible
Now when I finally decided to go away, you came along. I won't go back to my tasks. No way
I've just decided to erase myself from this world once and for all
You'll be better off without me take the chance
I'm giving you enjoy your lives go and tell everyone they don't need to be afraid anymore
yours faithfully
Yeah
But I mean the world without death. Is that really a world worth I?
Mean I don't know
What does that mean?
You've unlocked nothing I unlocked nothing
Then the next episode is the last
chapter apparently
Why why death go away is death and this kid the same person?
I don't know like maybe not because he communicated, but what makes sense in this world. It doesn't make sense ah
But either way, we'll find out in the next video
Thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you
In the next video bye. Bye